grand concours cinéma ticket star pour
cannes antennes de france soir voilà et
maintenant place au ciné club qui nous
présente ce soir candy mountain signé
rudy furent l'isère et ce film est le
premier des huit films qui vous seront
proposées dans le cadre de notre grand
concours antennes de france soir
regardez le attentivement car juste
après la fin de ce film nous vous
poserons une question et si vous trouvez
la réponse est bien vous serez peut-être
l'heureux gagnant d'un week end pour
deux personnes au festival de cannes
1990 alors demain dont françois vous
trouverez un bulletin réponse ainsi que
le règlement complet de ce grand jeu
concours et vous pouvez également
obtenir ce règlement et envoyez votre
réponse sur papier libre bonne chance à
tous candy mountain s'est tout de suite